[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonjour à tous saviez vous que plus de 2
milliards de personnes sur cette planète
n'ont pas accès à l'eau potable
savez vous que plus de 820 millions de
personnes sur ses terres n'ont pas accès
non plus à l'électricité alors moi c'est
des chiffres que j'ai découvert il ya
quelques années qui ont encore augmenté
depuis et alors je sais pas si vous avez
brillé arrivé à imaginer votre vie sans
eau et sans électricité
évidemment ça vont bien au delà de je
suppose que vous pensez directement
avait le matin quand je tourne groupe
pour me brosser les dents
le soir j'ai pas pouvoir regarder les
films il faut se rendre compte que
vraiment aujourd'hui c'est là c'est la
dure réalité de beaucoup de personnes et
aujourd'hui je vous faire part de mon
chemin vers le développement durable
mon chemin vers une solution à ce
problème mon chemin vers un impact
positif
donc il ya quelques années j'ai décidé
d'aller en côte d'ivoire pour mettre en
place une société qui s'appelle estia
synergies alors est-il synergies on a la
vocation de mettre en place des
solutions durables et innovantes afin
d'intensifier le développement socio
économique
alors ma première mission c'était une
instance publique qui nous a contactés
afin de développer les zones rurales en
côte d'ivoire donc ce que j'ai fait j'ai
directement été étaient sur place afin
de mieux comprendre
arrivé au sud comoé un petit village
dans un petit village en côte d'ivoire
j'ai rencontré le chef du village qui
m'a accueilli chaleureusement et qui m'a
fait pas directement monsieur adama qui
m'a fait part directement de ce problème
d'insécurité qui vivaient que tous ces
villages on arrivait le problème était
que entre chaque village il n'y avait
pas d'éclairage donc tous les soirs à
partir de 18 heures les gens ne
pouvaient plus circuler entre les
villages sous le risque de
de se faire écraser par une voiture se
faire agresser donc il y avait une
réelle à l'insécurité qui régnait
de plus le manque d'électricité au sein
même du village limite l éducation pour
pour les jeunes étudiants car à partir
de 18 heures il devenait presque
impossible de lire et écrire
j'ai continué mon chemin dans le village
et là j'ai une petite fille qui m'avait
qui m'a interpellé une petite fille de
france 14 15 ans très très musclé mais
j'étais j'étais presque jalouse je la
vois très très forte et donc m intrigue
la suit du regard et là je la vois pompe
et une sorte de grosse machine en métal
et en fait je m'en rends compte que
cette petite fille de 14 ans en train de
pomper l'eau après deux je pense 100
mètres de profondeur juste par la force
de ses mains j'ai essayé après et c'est
vraiment un exercice très difficile et
en fait au delà du côté du côté
compliquée du côté pénible de la tâche
je me suis rendu compte en fait en
parlant aux villageois que c'est le sort
de milliers de femmes et de jeunes
filles est en fait ce qu'on se rend
compte c'est que le fait qu'elles
doivent pomper cette eau tout et toute
la journée ça les empêche d'étudier la
journée ça les empêche de se développer
un maximum
on s'est rendu compte aussi que
certaines femmes était enceinte et
devait pomper aussi cette eau et à yale
il ya un réel risque de fausse couche
donc voilà tout ça pour vous dire que
c'est un impact considérable fait de ne
pas avoir de l'eau potable
c'est un impact sur l'éducation il ya un
impact énorme sur la santé parce qu'en
plus faut se dire que ces jeunes femmes
et ces jeunes filles qui vont chercher
de l'eau prowler villageois avec plein
de bonnes intentions parfois ramène de
l'eau contaminée carlo et simplement
pompe et elle n'est pas filtrée et est
ce que ce que je veux dire par là c'est
que c'est tout un écosystème en fait ces
jeunes femmes qui de 1 apporte de l'eau
contaminée vous contaminer leurs
concitoyens ses concitoyens ne pourront
pas travailler par la suite vont tomber
malade pire parfois mourir et de plus on
empêche les jeunes femmes c'est au défi
de travailler de se développer elles ne
pourront pas par la suite avoir leur
impact positif sur leur âge elles ne
pourront pas à impacter le développement
socioéconomique de leur village
je sais pas si vous vous rendez compte
mais vous aujourd'hui je pense que tout
le monde dans cette salle quand vous
cherchez de l'eau il vous faut quelques
mètres et quelques secondes eu ces
quelques kilomètres parfois et quelques
heures alors j'ai continué mon chemin
dans le village et là j'ai rencontré
ahmed un petit agriculteur très sympa et
ce qui m'a choqué c'est que ils étaient
illettrés
parce que c'est passé qui est choquant
parce que je veux dire c'est que ils
étaient illettrés donc il n'a eu ni il
ne lit pas le journal il n'a pas
l'électricité donc il n'a pas accès aux
nouvelles
et pourtant ils étaient bien conscients
du dérèglement climatique il était bien
conscient parce qu'il vit tous les jours
et il me disait qu en fait à l'époque
c'était très facile vous allez la saison
des pluies la saison sèche cx mois pour
la saison sèche 6 mois pour la saison
des pluies vous savez quand la pluie
arrive vous savez quand la pluie
s'arrête vous pouvez contrôler contre
complètement votre votre votre
agriculture élus ne savait plus le faire
ils ne savaient plus le faire il avait
perdu un total contrôle sur son sur son
agriculture et ça a un impact
considérable non seulement sur ahmed qui
évidemment va perdre un revenu est
énorme mais ça va avoir un impact au
final sur sa famille sa famille après ne
pourra plus payer l'éducation de ses
enfants s'est dit que ses enfants ne
pourront donc pas aller à l'école avoir
un avenir meilleur pouvoir rendre à leur
village pouvoir développer leur village
donc je pense que c'est ça qui est très
important pour vous de comprendre que
c'est tout un écosystème on a chacun
notre rôle à jouer et chacun l'impact
positif ou négatif à voir donc voilà je
suis rentré après après toute cette
histoire je suis rentré à abidjan est là
on a réfléchi avec nos ingénieurs la
meilleure des solutions
et alors on s'est dit on a réfléchi
d'abord à ce qu'ils avaient sur place
alors en côte d'ivoire il ya une maman
de soleil il ya énormément d'eau des
nappes phréatiques et il y a énormément
de main d'oeuvre jeune et dynamique et
donc on s'est dit au lieu d'amener les
des solutions hyper compliqué la manière
des technologies on s'est dit et
utilisons ce qu'il est aujourd'hui
lorsqu'on a fait c'est qu'on a utilisé
l'énergie solaire donc dans un premier
temps pour résoudre le problème de
l'insécurité très simplement on a mis
des lampadaires partout dans le village
entre les villages afin d'éclairer
augmenter la sécurité
et ça c'est très simple vous mettez vous
faites trois trous vous mettez le
lampadaire solaire et c'est réglé
il n'y a pas besoin de tirer des câbles
très loin jusqu'à abidjan et donc il n'y
a pas besoin d'avoir des solutions high
tech pour résoudre des problèmes
compliqués les problèmes compliqués ont
bien souvent des réponses très simple
par la suite on a voulu résoudre
évidemment le problème d'eau potable
ce qu'on l'a fait simplement c'est aussi
à utiliser l'énergie solaire
on a utilisé les gens c'est l'énergie
solaire de façon très simple on a
utilisé le pouilly le forage existant on
a mis une pompe à eau solaire on a fait
trois troupeaux m le château d'eau donc
on met une intrus quand on construit le
château d'eau
d'un autre côté on a mis le lampadaire
solaire pour sécuriser la zone on a fait
un autre ou pour mettre les rampes de
distribution d'eau et s'était joué en
une semaine de temps nous avons utilisé
les énergies locales le soleil la main
d'oeuvre locale et nous avons pu donner
de l'eau potable à 1000 habitants
de plus grâce à cela nous avons aussi
éduquer les gens à cette nouvelle
technologie et les gens en sont
ressortis avec des nouvelles
connaissances et ainsi pouvoir être plus
valorisées sur le marché du travail et
ainsi pouvoir aussi développer leurs
villages par la suite
qui peut le plus peut le moins nous
avons lu voulu résoudre le problème
agricole très simple nous avons utilisé
les mêmes systèmes et nous n'avons nous
avons simplement pas filtrer l'eau nous
avons simplement pomper l'eau et la
stocker pour les poulets
pour ahmed l'agriculteur donc c'est ce
qui est important c'est surtout
d'apporter des solutions adaptées
nous ce qu'on a fait aujourd'hui c'est
pas de m comme je vous ai dit la
dernière technologie on aurait pu par
exemple mettre des lampes uv avec tout
ce qui est automatique vous mettez vous
appuyez sur le bouton et tout fonctionne
le problème avec ça vous mettez des
solutions comme ça dans les villages
après deux semaines après un mois il ya
un problème personne ne sait les régler
impossible il faut faire 3h 4h 5h 7h de
route pour aller jusqu'à abidjan après
un mois vos solutions ne sert à rien
elle est jolie la première semaine pour
l'inauguration mais après ça servira
plus à rien donc nous on a vraiment
adapter la solution on a on a fait des
filtrations des ultras filtration afin
de réduire un maximum les consommables
et nous avons aussi transformer cette
ces stations complètement mécanique nous
avons enlevé tout le côté automatique
afin de réellement faire un transfert de
connaissances à la population locale
afin que ces personnes puissent réparer
par eux-mêmes donc ce que je veux dire
en fait part par toute cette histoire
c'est qu'en fait aujourd'hui et c'était
à synergy on n'a pas apporté une
solution n'a pas on n'a pas révolutionné
le monde
on n'a pas résolu le problème de
développement socio économique
on a simplement enlever le frein à main
afin que la voiture parts et que le
développement socioéconomique se lance
afin que les gens ont des outils afin
que ahmed puisse développer son champ
afin que la faim qui mène la jeune fille
qui devait pomper puissent aller à
l'école afin qu'il paie afin qu'ils
puissent se développer par même avoir
les outils fondamentaux pour développer
lors leur potentiel donc voilà tout ça
pour dire que le développement durable
en fait il est en chacun de vous tout le
monde tout le monde peut avoir son
impact pour donner une pauvre pour
illustrer sa je vais utiliser une
métaphore de l'iceberg
parce que je pense que souvent quand on
pense au développement durable on voit
toujours grand quand on veut on veut
changer le monde on veut sauver le monde
comme bill gates qui fait un million de
truc c'est très bien mais il faut se
rendre compte que l'iceberg
on voit que la partie au dessus il ya
toute une partie submergée qui est
énorme
donc en fait il ya toute une équipe
derrière tout ça et chacun a son rôle à
jouer
je vous donne un exemple pour ça
exemple moi quand je suis arrivé à
quelques années j'ai deux femmes ont
énormément aidés c'est ma secrétaire et
ma femme ménages et je pense que peu de
gens surtout par exemple mes clients ou
les utilisateurs finaux qui utilisent
nos pompes à eau se disent que ma
secrétaire ou ma salle de ménages ont
apporté de l'eau et on participe de
participer au développement socio
économique
en réalité ils ont eu un impact énorme
elles m'ont permis d'avoir une
tranquillité d'esprit ma secrétaire à
m'aider dans tout le côté administratif
à me soutenir moralement ma femme de
ménage en rentrant que tout soit propre
elle m'a accueillie comme une mère et il
y à elles m'ont apporté une tranquillité
d'esprit et m'ont permis de prendre
toute mon énergie pour la remettre dans
le développement durable
donc je pense que ce qui est très
important de retenir aujourd'hui c'est
que chacun à son impact positif ou
négatif
donc si vous devez sortir avec une
question de vos têtes c'est la suivante
quel impact voulez vous avoir
[Applaudissements]